now well whatever the outcome in this
these gop primaries tonight it's time to
put aside differences
shelve the petty squabbles a lot of
nipping at each other all come back
together to take back the senate in
november
now under one of control by the schumer
pelosi socialists america is going broke
woke and becoming a joke it's time for
real oversight of biden's runaway
federal agencies it's time to slam the
brakes on his inflation-stoking agenda
with of course a
republican-controlled congress
but the left they're not going to go
down without a fight no way they're
going to try to hang on to their power
by any means necessary now when they're
not blowing up the economy they're
blowing up race relations they're
shifting blame or as we all know they're
distracting with phony narratives
look the american experiment
in democracy
is in a danger
like it hasn't been in my lifetime it's
in danger this hour
hate and fear of being given too much
oxygen
by those who pretend to love america i
believe anybody reckons a replacement is
to blame not for this particular crime
but it's it's for no purpose
no purpose except profit
and or political benefit and it's wrong
he's always hearkening back to trump
right the ghost of trump is always
hovering over biden but my lord is this
playbook dog-eared or what
most voters know that charlottesville or
january 6 buffalo they're all biden's
greatest hits they're not america's
greatest hits
this isn't going to work
so you have to ask yourself what's next
for the democrats
well i'm going to call it tonight the
populist pivot democrats are going to
try to claim that they not republicans
that were republicans challenging them
are the true populists that they're the
ones out there fighting for the little
guy
their i'm relatable ploy is their go-to
desperation move
i'm glad for everybody who's joining
this video it's great to hear from you
hold on a sec i'm gonna get me
um a beer
hey
whatever my husband bruce is now in here
um
you want a beer i'll pass on the beer
for now
oh my god i forgot about that
and then there's senator john tester in
montana with his flat top buzz cut and
tough guy farmer look he tried the same
thing back in 2018.
washington forgets all the time that
they're working for us
when some bureaucrat back there stands
in the way of montana i let them have it
because if that's what it takes to get
better schools well i'm wired to fight
anyone who isn't doing their job for us
i'm jon tester and you damn right i
approve this message
you're damn right you vote with schumer
all the time of course at practice he's
just another big spending liberal
we need to start doing some things in a
positive way to lower inflation
we did it with a bipartisan
infrastructure big deal
we did it with the rescue plan
what
the fact is the so-called moderates like
tester and georgia's senator raphael
warnock he's up for reelection the only
voice concern about issues like the
border or inflation when it was obvious
that these issues were hurting their
party in the midterms
where were they in 2020 or last year
in the big open senate seat contest two
more liberals are attempting this
transparent branding congressman tim
ryan trying to beat jd vance in ohio and
john fetterman taking on whoever wins
tonight in pennsylvania
now ryan who voted with nancy pelosi
wait for it
100 of the time according to pro publica
is now pretending to be donald trump on
the china issue
defunding the police is way off the mark
we need more cops not less my party also
got it wrong on the trade deals that
sent your jobs overseas i've always
fought those working against you
yeah
of course this complete nonsense believe
none of it a vote for ryan is a vote for
chuck schumer remaining a senate
majority leader on important issues at
key moments he will never challenge his
party's leadership never
and as for john fetterman we wish him of
course a speedy recovery
but pennsylvanians shouldn't be fooled
by the whole sweatshirt and gym shorts
look
it's sloppy and unconvincing just like
this ad
there's a lot of great towns in
pennsylvania that feel like their
community's best days were a generation
ago
no one deserves to be abandoned all
these communities deserve to be helped
democrat with backbone does the right
thing no matter what
no matter what
i mean the right thing for fettermen
will always be keeping chuck schumer
happy always
now with the occasional exception of joe
manchin and christian cinema there's no
such thing anymore as a really
independent thinking democrat
take senator mark kelly now arizonans
voted for him because after all how can
a former astronaut be a rubber stamp for
liberalism doesn't compute
but in fact that exactly what he's been
voting with schumer 96
of the time
now he must really think his own voters
are stupid though because suddenly after
a monk-like silence about biden's
failures
kelly claims he cares
arizonans are paying some of the highest
gas prices that we've seen in years for
months i've pushed this administration
to take action to lower costs at the gas
pump
it's time to send him back into orbit
don't you think
there's there's no oxygen in his
populist act zero
now any voter who wants to turn this
economy around wants to end the madness
at the border
simply cannot fall for the democrats
faux populist pitch
why would george soros donate money to
people like tim ryan after all or
senator mark kelly
if they were going to take on the
establishment
here's what we know by the way about
soros's cash pouring in billionaire mega
donor george soros is seating a super
pac with 125 million dollars an enormous
investment that will aid democratic
groups and candidates for the 2020
election cycle and beyond
so soros knows what time it is in the
democrat party and it ain't the populist
time
it's all globalists all the time
so pay no attention to the democrats
predictable masquerade unfolding months
before the midterms we've seen all this
before
they're sending the same people who are
going to be spending your children's and
your grandchildren's future squandering
it
the same people willing to do the
bidding of the teachers unions in blm
and the same people who have only
strengthened china's hand
and made you poorer
so when you head to the polls this
november your choice is clear
do you want more of schumer and pelosi
then go ahead
vote for the populist frauds
otherwise
it's time to unite
and fight and that's the angle hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else